para evitar la expansión de casos de
viruela del mono alemania compra 40.000
dosis de una vacuna existente a un
laboratorio danés para aplicarlas a
personas que han tenido contacto con
infectados
la vacuna es sin duda un desarrollo
adicional de las vacunas convencionales
contra la viruela y está diseñado
específicamente para ser una alternativa
más segura la vacuna se originó en el
instituto estatal de baviera y se
desarrolló allí en las décadas de 1960 y
cuando la campaña de vacunación contra
la viruela original aún estaba en curso
blau flow en francia se vacunará a los
adultos en riesgo de contagio lo mismo
hará dinamarca las autoridades
sanitarias consideran que no ven posible
que haya una nueva pandemia y que el
brote puede contenerse la bebé se está
publicando orientaciones también sobre
las vacunas y las consideraciones de
inmunización pero lo más importante en
este momento es darse cuenta de que este
brote puede ser contenido debido al
rastreo de los contactos y al
aislamiento lado ms reporta más de 200
casos entre sospechosos y confirmados en
10 países la mayoría europeos los
síntomas de la enfermedad incluyen
fiebre inflamación de los nódulos
linfáticos dolores de cabeza cansancio
muscular y erupciones cutáneas la forma
de contagio según las investigaciones
preliminares es por contacto sexual
estrecho e intercambio de fluidos la
viruela del mono que es endémica en
áfrica occidental desde hace 40 años y
tiene una tasa de mortalidad de
alrededor del 1 por ciento fue contenida
en el continente durante la pandemia de
kobe 19